There are some remarkable cities dotted around
the world but what about the ones that have
been consigned to the past?
Today we look at 9 amazing cities that were
once bustling hubs, full of life but are now
a mere shell of their former selves, forever
lost to history.
Our first lost city is in south-western USA
and it was probably abandoned by the 14th
century.
White immigrants rediscovered it in the late
1800s.
The local Native American’s obviously knew
of its existence but left these sacred ancestral
sites uninhabited.
Mesa Verde in Colorado is a large national
park and it holds around 4,300 ancient dwellings,
with the largest being Cliff Palace.
This giant 150 room structure follows the
shallow curve of an overhanging cliff and,
with its sandstone wall, looks like it’s
been carved right out of the rock.
And if you’re thinking, wait; that’s not
a city, remember this was built after a long
history of nomadic travelling.
The people would constantly be on the move,
following the seasons and the various animals
that they hunted.
So to build something this big and this permanent
was impressive.
It would be just like you coming from a tiny
farming village and getting off the train
in New York.
Historians call the people Puebloans, from
the Spanish “pueblo” meaning town.
They started building permanent structures
in around 750 AD, as a way to store food for
longer, probably to get some down time when
they were sick of running after buffalo.
As settlements grew, they increased their
reliance on farming since they could no longer
move with the migrating animals.
Plus, the more they built, the more wood they
needed and so the less forest there was for
them to forage and hunt in.
So what happened to its inhabitants?
Well, unlike many great Native American peoples,
it wasn’t the early settlers who drove them
out of their homes.
More likely it was a changing climate and
a series of mega-droughts in the 13th century
which hindered their farming.
No matter how cool your house is, you’re
not going to stay if you can’t eat.
We’re heading around the other side of the
world now, to Ancient Mesopotamia, which is
considered by many to be the cradle of civilization.
With creations such as writing, metallurgy
and farming, they started the long journey
that led to you being able play Angry Birds,
on your smartphone, whilst eating a Big Mac.
And Mesopotamia housed one of mankind’s
greatest cities; Babylon.
At its peak, it had a population of over 200,000
people, which was around 0.003% of the world’s
population, or to put that in modern terms,
it would be over 20 million people.
Only Tokyo is bigger than that right now.
The city has a long and violent story and
empires have risen and fallen around it.
It appeared in history around 2300 BC, although
who built it and exactly when are a little
fuzzy, since 3000 years of bad filing have
meant it’s kind of difficult to find the
original planning application.
After 2000 BC the rise of the Babylonian empire
began and the city became the key holy place
of Mesopotamia and was likely the largest
city in the world at that point.
It went through a bit of a slump, but hey,
we all do, and then grew again to greatness
between 600 – 300 BC.
It’s been ruled by such leaders as Nebuchadnezzar,
who created the famous Hanging Gardens of
Babylon, and by Alexander the Great.
When Alexander died, the battle to take over
his power basically emptied the city.
I can only imagine his wake was full of big
egos and an awful lot of wine.
It was also supposedly the home of the mythical
Tower of Babel, which was written about in
the book of Genesis.
The tower was built to reach all the way up
into the heavens and the architects hoped
it would act as a sign that their people would
remain and not be spread out across the world.
But then God came down and threw a spanner
in the works by making everyone speak a different
language, so they had to wander off to separate
corners of the earth.
You could read this all as an allegory, showing
that Mesopotamia really was the birthplace
of all civilizations.
So where is Babylon now?
Its ruins lie in modern day Iraq.
In the 1980s, Saddam Hussein started to rebuild
parts of it to demonstrate the great history
of the Arab region.
He also decided to add a huge portrait of
himself and Nebuchadnezzar and inscribed “this
was built by Saddam Hussein, son of Nebuchadnezzar,
to glorify Iraq”.
If you’re going to be a twisted, evil dictator,
you may as well do it with style.
Now we travel south, across the Mediterranean
to reach Carthage, a lost city on the tip
of Tunisia, at Africa’s point closest to
Italy.
The area is now a suburb of the Tunisian capital;
Tunis, but it was once the great power hub
of the area, the base of a naval empire.
The city was created by Phoenician colonists
in about 814 BC, travelling over from their
home, in what is now known as Lebanon.
They were led by their queen, Dido - no, not
the late 90s British pop artist.
Queen Dido was worshipped for many years after
her death, this was largely due to her flamboyant
end.
A rival king was threatening to invade Carthage
if she didn’t consent to marry him.
She built a huge pyre, pretending that she
was burning everything that reminded her of
her previous, now deceased, husband.
But at the final moment she leapt onto the
fire and fell on her own sword.
Now that’s what I call a rejection; it makes
someone not showing up to a date seem rather
mild in comparison.
“Do you want to go out with me?”
“I’d rather fall on my own sword, whilst
simultaneously enveloped in flames.”
“Think I’ll take that as a no then.”
Carthage was actually very difficult to attack
though, with its massive navy of 220 warships
and an enormous 37 kilometres of wall surrounding
it.
In fact, it wasn’t until 146 BC that it
first fell.
The Romans, who were in a pretty bad mood
from dealing with Hannibal (the Carthaginian
military commander, not the cannibal) for
15 years, took the city.
They then burnt the ships and sold some 50,000
Carthaginians into slavery.
The Romans then built it up into one of the
largest cities in their empire.
The Vandals took it over for a while but eventually,
in 698 AD there was the second great battle
of Carthage.
The armies of Umayyad, one of the large Islamic
Caliphates, completely destroyed the city,
cutting off its water, tearing down the walls
and wrecking the harbour.
It really ruined its retail value.
Our next city was left half-abandoned in the
jungle for around 300 years but has now become
one of the world’s largest tourist attractions.
Angkor Wat is the largest religious monument
in the world and is the pride of Cambodia,
even featuring on their national flag.
Constructed in the 12th century by King Suryavarman
II, it was originally designed as a Hindu
temple but had become Buddhist by the end
of the century.
This was mainly due to a change in the beliefs
of the land.
The beautiful temples we see now are only
a small part of what used to exist though.
Angkor was in fact the largest pre-industrial
city in the world and between 1010 and 1220
it held at least 0.1% of the world’s population
within its 1000 square kilometre sprawl.
There are a number of theories as to why this
architectural marvel ended up mostly deserted.
There was an uprising against a ruler from
Siam in 1431, since the Siamese had taken
control of the city some 80 years earlier.
This probably led a large portion of people
to migrate out of the city.
But it could also have been a mixture of floods,
earthquakes and the bubonic plague; hopefully
not all at once, that would have been a really
bad week.
So Angkor was left to rot in the jungle and
some monks stayed on in the temple, which
is most of what remains of the city today.
The large moat, that surrounds the holy building,
mostly protected it from the encroaching vegetation
and from the bullets and shells of the Cambodian
civil war.
Ironically, despite all the conservation work,
it’s now under more threat than ever since
all of those tourists marching over the sandstone
and using up the ground water are weakening
the buildings day by day.
The damage of 500 years of jungle growth is
nothing compared to what a little kid with
a football and an ice cream can do.
Okay, let’s come out of the jungle and head
to higher ground.
Machu Picchu sits almost two and a half kilometres
above sea level and had a brief but mysterious
history.
The Incas built it in 1450 but we are still
unclear as to its purpose.
Since the site, although very beautiful, has
no real strategic benefit in terms of trade
or food or power.
Perhaps it was just a king trying to be difficult,
you know how kings are.
The most likely reason is that it was some
sort of royal retreat, like the US president’s
Camp David, or Hitler’s Eagle’s Nest up
in the mountains of Bavaria.
No eagles for the Incas though, they had the
large stone Altar of the Condor where they
would perform human sacrifices and the birds
would come and remove the carcasses.
The Incas were quite advanced and the construction
of some of Machu Picchu’s temples is so
accurate that you can’t even fit a sheet
of paper between the stonework, meaning it
holds together without mortar.
The stepped terraces of the city are also
a very smart way of adapting the mountain
to the needs of the city.
Surprisingly, their civilisation never got
around to inventing the wheel, although perhaps
if you’re over 2 kilometres up a hill, the
last thing you want is to see your cart rolling
off down into the nearest valley.
In just over 100 years, the city was deserted,
possibly due to the devastation caused by
smallpox, which the Conquistadors brought
with them from Spain; what a lovely welcome
gift.
On to Italy now and into a bay on the west
coast that also holds the city of Naples.
Naples has existed in some form for around
3000 years, making it one of the longest continuously
inhabited places on earth.
But across the other side of the bay lies
Pompeii, and Pompeii was not quite so lucky.
In 79 AD, the entire Roman city was destroyed
and buried under a huge mound of ash and pumice
up to six metres deep, killing some 16,000
people, when Mount Vesuvius erupted.
A mixture of ash, stones and gases were blown
33 kilometres into the air and an astonishing
1.5 million tonnes of pumice and molten rock
were spat out of the volcano every second!
This ended the 500-year history of Pompeii,
having been built at some point around 700-600
BC.
So, I guess some of you are thinking; why
build your city next to a giant volcano?
That just seems like trouble.
Well, it was actually a pretty quiet volcano
then, since the previous eruption had been
a relatively small one almost 200 years before.
Still, 16 years before the eruption that destroyed
Pompeii, there was a huge earthquake that
took out a lot of the city and led to looting
and chaos.
This was less a red flag, more an entire flag
factory making 10 metres square banners saying
“move away from the giant fire bucket”.
Excavation of the city began in 1738 when
workmen discovered it whilst digging the foundations
for a summer palace.
It’s a huge tourist attraction with much
of the art and buildings restored.
Vesuvius hasn’t erupted since 1944.
But with 30 separate eruptions since 79 AD,
this vivacious volcano shows no signs of stopping
and poses an enormous threat to the 3 million
people who now live within 20 miles of its
crater.
For our next city we travel to the deserts
of Jordan.
Petra was a city carved into the walls of
looming sandstone, which form a natural fortress
around it.
It lay on the key caravan route through to
Gaza and the Red Sea so it was the centre
of Nabataen trade.
The Nabateans were described as “one of
the most gifted people of the ancient world”
and it’s hard to argue with.
The Petra we see now, of stunning tombs cut
with beautiful detail, and ingenious waterways
that made an arid land thrive, was probably
built around the 1st century.
At the same time in ancient Britain, we were
pretty pleased that the romans had invaded
so we didn’t have to live in a circle of
mud and sticks anymore.
The tombs and temples are often much smaller
inside than their grand entrances would suggest
but, despite this, experts believe that we
have only uncovered around 15% of what is
there.
There are many secrets yet to be found.
Some Bedouin tribes believe there is treasure
in the rocks and you can see the bullet holes
where they have tried to shoot it out.
The Romans came along in 106 AD and the city
began to empty as its importance as a trade
route decreased and by 700 AD it was consigned
to history.
If you don’t want to make the long journey
to see the ancient city, you’ll be glad
to know it’s on Google street view so you
can enjoy some of its wonders without even
having to get dressed.
Our final two cities have more of an air of
mystery around them since we have no definite
proof that they actually existed, nor do we
know exactly where they could have been.
Our first legend is the magical city of gold;
El Dorado
In the earlier versions of the story, El Dorado
was a man and may have been the king of the
native Muisca people, a tribe from near modern
day Bogota in Columbia.
When a new king was appointed, he would be
covered in gold dust and then dipped into
the waters of Lake Guatavita while his onlookers
also threw in gold jewellery.
From the mid 16th century and for hundreds
of years after, many attempts to find the
city were made but nothing was ever found.
A lot of the myth was fuelled by the fact
that the conquistadors saw many of the local
people wearing gold, without seeming to understand
its value, so they assumed there must be some
huge stash of it somewhere.
One failed attempt resulted in the discovery
of a great river and when a tribe of warrior
women chased the explorers off, their similarity
to a Greek myth was noted and the river was
named; the Amazon.
The English explorer, Sir Walter Raleigh led
two great expeditions to Venezuela, aiming
to find El Dorado and to establish an English
colony in South America and disrupt the Spanish
trade with the native people.
On the second journey he was on strict orders
not to get into any battles with the Spanish
due to the delicate politics back home.
Raleigh stayed on the island of Trinidad but
his son was killed in an inevitable fight
with the Spanish.
When Raleigh returned home, he was beheaded
for disobeying orders.
I’m not sure what they really expected though,
fighting the Spanish was pretty much a national
pastime around that time.
Since the city El Dorado proved impossible
to find, many resorted to searching Lake Guatavita.
There were many attempts but surely the best
was when a London company drained the whole
lake in 1898 and were annoyed to find that
the remaining mud baked as hard as concrete
in the jungle sun, making it almost unpassable.
They uncovered a pathetic £500 worth of gold
for their efforts.
They probably made more money in free drinks
when they told the story in the pub back home.
And finally, the most famous lost city of
them all; Atlantis.
The legend of an island lost to the sea has
kept going for thousands of years but no evidence
has ever been found and there is a general
consensus amongst historians that it has no
real basis in truth.
Its origin is largely down to the Greek philosopher
Plato who discussed an imaginary island as
part of his work The Republic which he used
to explore the idea of a perfect state.
In the story, Ancient Athenians are the only
people able to defend against Atlantean attack
and the island itself loses favour with the
gods who decided to submerge it into the Atlantic
Ocean.
Probably a bit harsh but then Greek gods aren’t
exactly famous for their calm demeanour and
balanced decision making, they were far too
engrossed with drinking, incest and making
animals with lots of heads.
Plato’s story stuck though and there have
been hundreds of proposed sites for this lost
city; everywhere from the Mediterranean to
the Antarctica and even the Bermuda Triangle.
The people of Atlantis were rumoured to be
a technologically advanced super race with
submarines and aircraft.
But if they were so smart, why didn’t they
do something when they noticed the sea levels
were rising around them.
Or maybe they did and we just haven’t found
them yet.